et pour cette recette un binôme de choc
le professeur et chef jean benoît
pelletier et son élève canal coûtant
bien alors pour cette recette
nous allons avoir besoin d'une courge
butternut à ce risotto aux butternut on
va bien sûr besoin d'une courge
butternut qu'on va éplucher couche est
coupée en morceaux
harry arize auto qui est un riz arborio
du parmesan qu'on aura râpé et puis on
va utiliser bien entendu du chorizo à
deux moments de la recette en petits
cubes et aussi en poudre réduite ont
décoré avec une petite pluches de
cerfeuil pour commencer eh bien on va
attaquer avec une échalote que cannes
elle va ciselé c'est-à-dire qu'elles
découpent l'échalote en petits morceaux
l'idée c'est d'essayer de faire des
morceaux qu'ils soient pas plus gros
qu'un grain de riz et puis pendant ce
temps là nous on va pouvoir commencer à
venir faire chauffer de l'huile d'olive
dans un récipient et c'est huile d'olive
quand elle est bien chaude et bien on va
y mettre à l'intérieur notre échalotes
que cannes elle nous a ciselé pour la
faire suer gentils mots
l'objectif c'est d'éviter que sakho
l'ordre de trop il faut surtout pas que
ça colore et quand c'est fait on va
jeter à l'intérieur notre riz qu'on va
nacré ça veut dire qu'on va venir
l'enrobé tout doucement avec du l'huile
d'olive ont des glaces avec du vin blanc
et ensuite cannelle on va venir mouiller
avec du bouillon et on va le laisser
cuire tout doucement en remuant de temps
en temps ça va nous donner notre vie
zotto qui est cuit et notre courge
butternut qu'on aura fait cuire dans
l'eau avec une bonne quantité de sel on
va la réduire en purée on va mélanger
tout ça l'idée c'est de replacer la
crème de liaison habituellement du
risotto trr lab ethernet
et ça m'a permis d'avoir quelque chose
de plus léger ou un loup et en plus ça
légumes de saison une belle couleur
orange donc on aura vraiment quelque
chose de très sympa on a coupé des
petits morceaux de chorizo qu'on a fait
sauter à la poêle dans un petit peu
d'huile d'olive et on va du coup les
mettre à l'intérieur on continue à
aligner tous à une fois que s'est mis à
l'intérieur on pourra terminer avec le
parmesan râpé et on sera prêts à dresser
notre assiette
on a tous nos éléments
ils nous ont donc juste un conte a
terminé qu'on a préparé en avance c'est
une clio alors c'est notre secret à nous
on a fait vraiment cuir le chorizo font
presque noircir quand c'est fait on le
passe avec un petit mixeur pour le
réduire en poudre et comme ça on pourra
gentil mot dresser notre assiette et
venir décorer avec la poudreuse chorizo
pour avoir un risotto qu'hervé d'auto
bourmaud un risotto de saison un petit
peu relevé un petit peu épicée et donc
notre petite touche d'autres petits
secrets à nous c'est un peu de poudre de
chorizo noirci sur le dessus et surtout
on n'oublie pas un petit tour de moulin
à poivre pour avoir un beau
l'assaisonnement une peluche
et vous avez une jolie assiette qui est
prête à être dégustée et j'ai même la
mienne déjà et ben merci beaucoup à
table maintenant